[Musique]
et notre invité ce matin s'essayer
chavagné bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous êtes le président
de la cftc on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par christine
bertrand du groupe la dépêche
lauriane bonjour ciani et on commence
par la réforme de l'assurance chômage
bien sûr puisque vous avez rencontre
elisabeth bornes hier la limite du
travail qui vous a donc présenté sa
nouvelle feuille de route ces
modifications qu'elle souhaitait
apporter à la réforme de l'assurance
chômage
est-ce que du coup elle est devenue
acceptable pour vous cette réforme non
elle est toujours pas acceptable mais il
ya eu c'est vrai quelques modifications
quelques apports on va dire que la
réforme c'est s'est adouci un petit peu
si je peux me permettre ce terme on a eu
quelques éléments qui ont répondu à nos
attentes premièrement vous voulez pas
que la réforme soit appliquée au 1er
avril donc elle est reportée au 1er
juillet ce qui est plutôt un bon signe
nous envoyons aussi alors sur la
dégressivité sur laquelle nous sommes
toujours toujours opposés mais en tout
cas un petit délai supplémentaire
puisque elle sera appliquée qu'à partir
du neuvième mois et pas et pas du 7e
mois
donc voilà il ya eu sur toute une série
de mesures sur le calcul du salaire aux
journaliers aussi un adoucissement sur
la prise en compte des des jours non
travaillés donc voilà toute une série on
va dire de deux petits gestes qu'il faut
qu'il faut noter il faut être objectif
mais mais ces petits gestes restent
insuffisants pour nous qu'est-ce qui
pourrait être suffisant pour vous quel
quel geste pourrait vous faire accepter
c'est très fin mais je pense qu'il y en
a trois qui sont qui me paraissent
indispensables la première chose et j'en
parlais à l'instant s'est arrêtée ce
principe de la dégressivité ça n'a
jamais fait ses preuves on l'a
d'ailleurs dans l'histoire récente on
l'a essayé puis retirée puis re essayé
puis retirer encore à nouveau parce que
justement on n'a jamais fait l'apport
que mettre en place une dégressivité
avait un impact sur la reprise de
l'activité
la deuxième chose c'est le calcul du
salaire journalier qui est extrêmement
difficile et en particulier et c'est ça
qui est problématique pour les plus
précaires une personne qui a travaillé à
plein temps durant les 24 derniers mois
et qui perd son travail aujourd'hui du
fait de la crise sera que peu impacté
mais ça va impacter fortement des
personnes qui alterne
des périodes d'activité des périodes
d'inactivité on peut perdre jusqu'à un
tiers de son allocation et là encore ça
pardonne principe qui selon nous est
faux le fait qu une faible indemnité
motive le demandeur d'emploi à retrouver
un travail
non souvent ça le laisse dans la
précarité et souvent ça le fait basculer
dans la solidarité alors si on paie plus
chômage pour demain lui payer le rsa
c'est pas forcément la bonne chose et la
troisième chose et là je pense et je
continue à me battre parce que je pense
qu'on peut encore peut-être faire bouger
quelques lignes c'est le principe des
droits rechargeables qui ont été alignés
sur la durée d'accès à l'indemnité ce
qui là est une aberration on peut être
en désaccord sur une logique par rapport
à une réforme et on peut acter des
désaccords mais là ce n'est même plus un
désaccord c'est un problème de cohérence
et de logique
à partir du moment où les droits
rechargeables et d'ailleurs à la cftc on
était ce qu'il y à quelques effets
pervers on était d'accord et ont la vie
dit à la ministre pour allonger un petit
peu cette période pour recharger ses
droits mais là le fait de la m de la
même durée que l'indemnité rend les
droits rechargeables complètement
inopérant donc en fait on les laisse sur
le papier mais dans la réalité il
n'existe plus donc soit on est logique
qu'ils ont dit que les droits
rechargeables n'existe plus soit on met
une durée inférieure et on a proposé la
cftc que ça passe à 4 mois 6 2 mais
l'indemnité va à 6 ce qui paraît être
quelque chose de raisonnable mais pour
que je continue à faire pressing et je
pense qu'on le prend comme peut-être
faire évoluer ça ça veut dire que là
c'est toujours pas définitif et on va
dire qu'il ya encore d asie définitif
mais il peut y avoir encore quelques
ajustements la marge dont celui là je
continue à garder espoir
alors elle n'a pas dit qu'elle est allée
qu'elle allait nous revoir mais on
continue à faire remonter certaines
voilà certaines remarques et je pense
que sur les droits rechargeables nos
remarques sont quand même pertinentes et
et je pense que c'est en réflexion donc
voilà j'ai juste tout fan de toute façon
on a un peu pour habitude à la cpc
jusqu'à la dernière minute jusqu'à la
dernière seconde d'essayer de faire
bouger quelques quelques lignes donc
vous êtes vraiment sur des questions de
fond plus que sur des questions de
timing parce qu'on a dit c'est peut-être
mal bon moment non plus appliquer cette
réforme dont on va discuter
elle avait dès qu'elles étaient décalés
dans le temps à cause de la crise due
qu'aux villes la crise n'est pas
terminée
c'est passé à votre sujet votre sujet
c'est vraiment les questions de fond il
ya les deux sujets il ya la question de
fond dont je viens de parler il ya aussi
la question du timing parce que une
partie de cette réforme joue quand même
sur le fait qu'on va avoir une reprise
on va dire elle était d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça qu'on met le 1er juillet en
disant qu'on doit être à peu près
peut-être sorti du cockpit si la
vaccination s'accélère et et qu'on va
avoir une balade des prémices de reprise
économique c'est un pari aujourd'hui qui
est vraiment risqué voire incertain
qui peut dire à quel moment cette
reprise économique va arriver donc non
je pense que le timing est pas forcément
et pas forcément le bon on pouvait on
pouvait le décaler encore surtout
d'ailleurs que si on prend cette réforme
n'est pas appliquée de la même façon
pour les demandeurs d'emploi que pour
les entreprises
parce que le bonus malus qui était aussi
un grand sujet de cette réforme
alors il ya la bonne nouvelle ça fait
partie des bonnes nouvelles c'est que la
ministre garde le principe du
bonus/malus hockey les syndicats étaient
très attachés
malgré des pressions assez forte du
patronat qui lui est imposée qui lui est
opposée et je rappelle que c'est pour
lutter contre les contrats les plus
précaires parce qu'on a vu une explosion
presque multiplié par 3 des contrats
extrêmement de cours est extrêmement
précaires dont c'est une bonne chose que
la ministre n'ait pas céder à ces
pressions et qu'elle met le bonus malus
en place mais on a décidé de neutraliser
l'année 2020 on peut comprendre c'est
une année très très particulière y
compris le premier semestre 2021 donc en
fait la période de référence va être du
1er juillet 2021 au 30 juin 2022 alors
la ministre nous dit voyez bien que les
deux calendriers commence au même moment
on commence pour eux les deux au premier
1er juillet 2021
oui mais sauf que ça la période de
référence pour les entreprises
l'application effective va se faire au
premier
et 2022 alors que l'application de la
réforme pour les demandeurs d'emploi il
la voit directement arrivé au 1er
juillet 2000 2021 doit y est on est on
est un peu en décalage et quand vous
entendez lisabeth bornes qui a dû vous
vous dire ça hier un lundi dans
plusieurs interviews elle dit encore ce
matin dans le parisien que cette réforme
à vise à lutter contre la précarité a
apporté plus d'équité dans le mode de
calcul des allocations chômage est ce
que c'est vrai alors il ya une partie
vrai sur sur le côté équitable il ya des
aberrations aujourd'hui et moi je
prenais un exemple depuis longtemps
d'ailleurs qu'elle a repris récemment
mais j'ai toujours content quand on
reprend un de mes exemples mais un
demandeur d'emploi qui travaillent trois
mois à temps plein ou en demandeurs
d'emploi qui travaillent six mois à mi
temps pour un même salaire à la fin ils
ont fait le même nombre d'heures ils ont
pas la même allocation
c'est complètement délirant c'est
exactement ce qu'elles disent n'être
donc ça c'est pas équitable et il
fallait le revoir et c'est pour ça qu'on
n'était pas opposé à revoir ce principe
donc il y avait des choses à faire
sauf que l'équité on le fait vers le bas
voilà c'est ça le problème c'est que que
là on met la même indemnité pour les
deux mois j'étais parfaitement d'accord
avec ça et la cftc étaient parfaitement
d'accord avec ça il y avait quelque
chose qui était inéquitable
mais le nouveau calcul qui est mis en
place va faire en sorte ruineront un
effet la même indemnité mais qui va
baisser
donc c'est c'est équitable mais vers le
bas et c'est là où on voit le le plus
gros problème est ce qu'il ya un risque
aujourd'hui que comme en italie on voit
que les caisses d'assurance chômage ont
de grandes difficultés en italie à payer
les indemnités ce cas un risque
aujourd'hui en france après la crise du
coc vide pas de faillite mais de grandes
difficultés financières et est ce que
cette réforme du coup était urgente
il n'y a pas de risque de faillite de
l'unedic et on arrivera et on continuera
arriver à payer
les les allocations chômage donc ya pas
ce risque là évidemment il ya un déficit
qui se creuse
je rappelle quand même que l'unedic
devait revenir à l'équilibré cette année
donc ça prouve aussi que le parisien se
veut d'ailleurs le gère pas trop mal et
avec cette crise de co vide c'est
retardé et on espère revenir à
l'équilibré en 2023 donc ça veut dire
que le déficit qui s'est creusée qui va
dépasser les 60 milliards va arrêter
d'augmenter à partir de 2023 et on peut
espérer même qu'il commence à diminuer
donc on a en fait retarder un petit peu
le remboursement du déficit de l'unedic
mais on arrive à faire l'unedic est
quand même un bon payeur donc il arrive
à emprunter assez facilement en cours
sur les marchés
donc ya pas de risque par rapport à ça
mais on a retardé le moment où on va
rembourser
ce déficit est la mesure alors et
d'ailleurs ces chiffres là sont sans
l'application de la nouvelle réforme
avec l'application de la nouvelle
réforme comme les indemnités devront
quand même baisser un petit peu le
déficit va aussi être et c'est
d'ailleurs souvent quand même l'une des
raisons aussi il ya quand même un petit
enjeu un petit enjeu financier même si
la ministre nous dit le contraire est ce
qui est aussi un enjeu politique dans le
fait de maintenir cette réforme malgré
l'opposition des syndicats est ce que
vous dites c'est peut-être parce qu
emmanuel macron je vais afficher une
réforme de plus à son bilan qui
maintient coûte que coûte cette réforme
je pense il ya forcément un enjeu
politique c'était il y avait deux
grandes réformes dans le royaume a pas
que de grandes réformes je veux pas être
ré de réducteur mais il y avait en tout
cas ces deux grandes réformes dans le
quinquennat du président qui était d'un
côté la réforme des retraites de l'autre
côté la réforme de l'assurance chômage
on voit que les retraites c'est
extrêmement compliqué on va y venir et
je pense qu'on va qu'on va en parler
l'assurance chômage c'était peut-être un
petit peu moins compliqué donc on santé
oui on sentait vraiment qu'il y avait la
volonté de au moins faire quelques
réformes et de faire celle-là ce que je
pense à un petit peu précipitée et ne va
pas voilà et a pas répondu à nos
attentes de leurs portes et un peu plus
longtemps qu on va y venir avec chris
thème est d'abord un dernier mot sur
cette réforme de l'assurance-chômage
crois que vous avez rendez vous avec les
autres syndicats
la journée pour pour faire un point
calvette la position y avait une
position commune des grandes centrales
syndicales sur cette réforme de
l'assurance-chômage une réforme et
qu'elle va et elle sait qu'elle va être
cette position écoutez il y avait déjà
eu un courrier commun des cinq
organisations juste avant la rencontre
juste avant leur rencontre avec madame
bornes là aujourd'hui l'ensemble des
organisations se sont déjà exprimés ont
déjà fait leur propre communiqué donc je
vois pas trop ce qu'on pourrait dire de
supplémentaires dans un dans un
communiqué commun maintenez votre
position voilà la bise à part qu'on
maintienne notre notre position après on
a quelques différences parce que
certains ne voient voilà ne voir aucune
avancée de la part du gouvernement
d'autres sont peu plus mesuré
parce qu'il faut quand même reconnaître
qu'il ya eu quelques gestes faire perdre
et la cgt enfin chacun voilà chacun je
vous lirai les communiqués des uns et
des autres et chacun défend sa position
mais par contre les tous d'accord pour
dire que ça reste insuffisant et que ça
reste insatisfaisant grandes réformes et
la grande réforme contestée c'est celle
des retraites le gouvernement n'a pas
totalement abandonné l'idée
de la faire avant la fin du quinquennat
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que c'est toujours aussi
inacceptable que ça l'était pas c'est
l'été hier alors je sais pas s'ils ont
abandonné l'idée ou pas parce qu'on
attend on entend un petit peu des choses
contradictoires donc c'est pas déjà
évident que ce matin dans le parisien
vous aller vous allez faire du coup ce
que vous en pensez
la priorité c'est de gérer la crise et
d'en sortir la réforme des retraites
c'est une réforme nécessaire mais elle
doit se faire dans le dialogue social je
ne sais pas de quoi seront faits les
prochains mois on verra en fonction de
l'évolution de la situation
à ce stade il n'y a pas de rencontre à
ce sujet prévu dans l'agenda social
voilà donc ça ça dit pas grand chose en
fait on est bien d'accord donc c est en
tout cas ça ne dit pas si on va leur
prendre cette réforme ou pas il ya 2 il
ya deux choses qui sont qui sont
différentes nous on a toujours été
favorable la cftc un régime universel
par points
donc on n'était pas opposé à la réforme
ça fait même dix ans qu'on réclame un
régime universel par points qui est
beaucoup plus juste parce qu'on peut se
mettre d'accord sur une chose je pense
c'est que le système actuel il est tout
sauf juste après quand on dit régime
universel par points
on peut le construire de manière très
différente et c'est là où on avoue on
avait des différences avec le
gouvernement particulier par exemple sur
sur l'âge pivot ou d'autres ou d'autres
principes
donc on n'était pas un accord sur la
façon dont il monte le régime universel
par poids mais là l'occurrence les
syndicats sont pas tous d'accord
certaines sont complètement opposés au
régime universel par points
d'autres comme nous sont favorables je
ne sais pas si on va le faire si on va
pas le faire en tout cas c'est pas le
moment de remettre le feu aux poudres
dont je pense qu'il faut être
extrêmement prudent avec cette réforme
moi si on va sur le principe d' acte et
le régime universel par points durant ce
quinquennat
j'ai pas de souci avec ça si on va bien
dans la réforme systémique sur le long
terme si maintenant est-ce qu'on peut
encore y aller dans la réforme
systémique la réforme systémique elle
avait été pensé à un moment où le régime
est l équilibre aujourd'hui c'est plus
du tout le cas est ce qu'on peut faire
cette réforme systémique non le la
réforme systémique n'a pas été pensé
dans un moment où le régime était en
tant que dans un moment où il ne fallait
pas toucher aux paramètres emmanuel
macron il ne voulait pas forcément
toucher aux paramètres au début
lorsqu'il a lancé cette réforme pendant
la campagne présidentielle
alors au début c'était qu'une réforme
systémique rapidement quand même on a eu
un peu les deux qui étaient côte à côte
on avait
la fois le travail l'idée de départ sur
la systémique est à la fois sur le par
amélie des prix on était alors la flemme
sans toucher aux paramètres et on espère
justement là encore la faire cette
réforme systémique telle qu'elle a été
conçue au départ mais on peut encore la
faire par contre on peut plus la sphère
de la même façon donc sa demande
enfin en fait on peut pas reprendre les
discussions là où elles se sont arrêtées
au moins ça remonte sa demande de tout
remettre à plat et donc à la limite la
solution mais c'est peut-être un petit
peu ce que dit la ministre s'est on
pourrait très bien aujourd'hui acté le
régime universel par points
dire aux partenaires sociaux on se remet
autour de la table parce qu'il faut
quand même il ya beaucoup de choses
qu'il faut repenser et c'est l'enjeu
aussi ça peut être
et ça sera sûrement l'enjeu de la
prochaine présidentielle en dix ans le
dialogue social fait voilà porte ses
fruits pendant un an
le prochain président le prochain
gouvernement prendra ou ne prendra pas
ce qui est proposé pendant lé au nom de
ceux de ce dialogue social de cette
concertation
donc pour vous de ce que vous comprenez
de ce matin d'elisabeth bornes et
peut-être de ce cas vous à dire et vous
en a parlé de non pas du tout inquiet
alors de ce que vous comprenez de ce
qu'a dit ce matin c'est qu'ils sont
gentiment en train de l'enterrer en tout
cas d'ici la fin du quinquennat que ça
sera plus tard bah écoutez je j'en suis
j'en suis pas sur auron isola il ya
plusieurs choses qui sont possibles soit
on va mettre en place un régime
universel par points en tout cas le
principe est on va se remettre autour
d'une table pour les labours et
concrètement soit il sera complètement
enterrée c'est pas trop le discours
qu'on entend en tout cas dans l'est plus
dans dans les plus hauts lieux soit ce
serait là vraiment le plus inquiétant
c'est qu'on commence à vous dire qu'il
va falloir penser au remboursement du
quoi qu'il en coûte
et là on nous dit il faudra peut-être
aller justement vers une réforme un peu
paramétrique parce que quand on parle
des difficultés et des déficits de la
protection sociale heures devant un il
faut dire heureusement qu'on a le
système de protection social commun on
est quand même partie des pays les mieux
protégés et heureusement et les
partenaires sociaux et les syndicats ils
sont pas pour rien mais la protection
sociale si on veut revoir les déficits
on va pas toucher aujourd'hui à la
branche maladie avec le co vide je vois
pas comment on va aller vers ça la
branche famille avec les difficultés qui
à cette solidarité là on va la garder
aussi
donc j'ai peur que très rapidement se
disent s'il faut commencer à rembourser
le quoi qu'il en coûte
la seule variable d'ajustement possible
ce soit les retraites et la sarre
mettrait le feu aux poudres
et si on doit parler du poids qu'il en
coûtait dieu et du remboursement d'abord
un monde peut étaler la dette mais si on
doit en parler il faut qu'on en parle
globalement si on commence à en parler
par le le principe de la réforme des
retraites mais ça va être une
catastrophe et le feu dans le pays et je
pense qu'on n'a pas besoin de ça en ce
moment
justement le feu dans le pays comment
vous voyez ces discussions si elles
avaient lieu à un moment où il est
difficile de contester par les les
billets traditionnelles manifestations
réunions publiques
est ce que ces réformes sont compliqués
à négocier eu égard au contexte
non je pense pas que le son que sont
difficiles à négocier par rapport par
rapport au contexte puis on arrive
encore à faire des mobilisations même si
c'est un peu plus compliqué dans le
contexte sanitaire
je crois pas qu'il y aura la volonté de
faire quelque chose qui pourrait
justement mettre mettre le feu au pays
je pense qu'on serait capable rhône et
en ayant doit être capable de montrer
que voilà on est on puisse repartir sur
une concertation
c'est simplement une volonté de dire on
remet les choses à plat et on redémarre
voilà et que le contexte a changé et
bien qu'on prenne en compte que ce
contexte a changé et que ça redemande du
dialogue
une concertation et de se revoir et de
tout remettre autour de la table
alors justement puisqu'on parle de la
crise sanitaire comment le syndicaliste
que vous êtes regarde la gestion de la
crise par par le gouvernement il dit
avoir beaucoup aidé les entreprises
est-ce que vous reconnaissez cet effort
là écoutez
évidemment il ya eu des efforts qui ont
été faits importants que ce soit pour
aider nos concitoyens avec le chômage
partiel je rappelle qu'à une certaine
époque on était à plus de 8 millions de
personnes en chômage partiel donc ce
serait malhonnête de dire qu'on n'a pas
aidé qu'on n'a pas aidé et au niveau des
entreprises les aide aussi ont été ont
été importantes donc l'argent a été mis
sur la table de manière conséquente le
quoi qu'il en coûte je pense que c'était
une bonne chose et ça a été effectif
c'était pas que pas que des mots après
un secteur n'a été oublié seul ou non je
pense que alors je
je suis pas spécialiste forcément de
tous les secteurs mais je pense pas que
que vraiment un secteur a été oubliée
après on est plutôt sur et c'est là où
on a des remarques que nous en tant que
syndicaliste plutôt sur sur l'efficacité
et si l'argent a été mis sur la table
je pense qu'on aurait pu faire
légèrement autrement en particulier sur
les aides aux entreprises
c'est ce qu'on demandait à ce qu'elle
soit peut-être mieux cibler plus
conditionné et c'est être là où il
manquait ce qui lui manquait sur le
terrain qu'est ce qui a manqué d'après
vous non la preuve la première chose
c'est le sait le ciblage qui a pas qu'à
pas été fait parce qu'on a traitées
toutes les entreprises de la même
manière accord or il ya des entreprises
qui se portait bien et pour lesquels il
faut faire le dos rond avec la crise du
coc vide et donc là il fallait les aider
de cette manière là il n'y a pas de
souci il ya d'autres entreprises qui
n'allait pas bien avant la crise du coc
vide alors évidemment ça n'a pas arrangé
les choses la crise du mobile mais qu'il
n'allait pas bien pour des choix
stratégiques du monde et management des
produits qui étaient dépassées enfin
toute une série de raisons il y en a pas
fait la différence entre les deux est là
pour ces entreprises là il fallait les
aider à la fois pour se reconvertir vers
des métiers d'avenir et des produits
d'avenir
il fallait lancer des reconversions pour
les salariés le fait de ged tout
simplement pour faire le dos rond
ça ne marche que pour des entreprises
qui se portent bien pour lequel on doit
attendre la reprise ça marche pas pour
les autres
alors c'était pas aussi évident à faire
mais c'était pas assez ciblées et pas
assez conditionner le quoi qu'il en
coûte selon vous il doit encore durer
jusqu'à la fin de la crise ou en étant
des limites aujourd'hui
non il doit mais je pense qu'il n'y a
pas trop de débats par rapport à ça on
sait que tant que la crise du coc videla
attend que des secteurs sont fermés et
tant qu'il ya des salariés qui ne
peuvent pas travailler il faut les aider
je pense que toutes les mesures qui sont
prises aussi bien au niveau des
entreprises qu'au niveau des salariés
vont perdurer jusqu'à ce qu'on soit on
va dire à peu près sorti et donc à ce
qu'une majorité de la population soit
vaccinée à propos de la vaccination
penser que la vaccination dans les
entreprises il ya la médecine du travail
c'est possible et c'est souhaitable
c'est une plutôt une bonne chose y
compris d'ailleurs les salariés
le demandent aujourd'hui c'était assez
réfractaire aux tout débuts sur la
vaccination je pense comme l'ensemble de
la population était un peu craintive
aujourd'hui il ya plus tôt cette volonté
d'aller vers le vaccin y compris dans
les entreprises il ya deux demandes
il ya la première que ce soit fait par
des par le pas par des spécialistes et
donc d'où l'intérêt de la médecine du
travail alors qu'ils se portent pas
toujours extrêmement bien donc il faut
aussi peut-être l'aider avec des
infirmières ou avec du personnel privé
et puis toute la partie on va dire qu'on
est fils confidentiel à la
confidentielle pardon excusez moi j'en
bafouille qui était important parce
qu'il faut pas que les informations par
rapport à cette vaccination aussi parce
que en basse et ça va concerner en
premier lieu des personnes fragiles et
donc il faut pas que l'entreprise puisse
s'en servir derrière avec des mauvaises
intentions
donc c'est ça en fait les enjeux qui
sont derrière et les seules petites
craintes mais le principe de la
vaccination à l'entreprise est une bonne
chose et dernière question de cristal
oui vous avez eu lundi des discussions
avec le gouvernement autour du
télétravail
quel est l objectif est ce que ça se
passe bien est ce qu'il ya des problèmes
alors en fait on essaie de faire
repartir un peu le télétravail parce
qu'il ya une certaine érosion voilà il y
avait que vous expliquer comment je
pense que ce soit au niveau des
entreprises ou au niveau des salariés on
commence une personne n'a envie
d'ailleurs c'est assez paradoxal parce
qu on a passé notre vie en tant que
syndicaliste et moi j'ai passé ma vie à
me battre pour mettre en place dans de
nombreuses entreprises le télétravail
mais le télétravail est une chose qui
est formidable
quand ces deux trois jours par semaine
le télé travail à temps plein est
quelque chose sur lequel on s'est
toujours opposé d'ailleurs dans l'accord
national interprofessionnel qu'on a fait
entre patronat et syndicats on a dix ans
semble que cinq lola que le télétravail
attendent complet n'était pas une bonne
chose
donc c'est difficile on n'est pas tous
égaux aussi au télétravail il faut avoir
des conditions agréables pour pouvoir le
faire et quand vous avez un appartement
de 35 m² à paris et que vous êtes
enfermé toute la journée dedans
forcément un petit peu marre donc on
voit qu'à une certaine érosion
c'est difficile de manager à distance
toute la semaine c'est difficile de
garder la culture de l'entreprise c'est
s'est dit c'est difficile de ne pas voir
ses collègues
les échanges informels aussi c'est
quelque chose qui est important dans le
cadre du travail
c'est compliqué de rester toute sa
journée devant devant un écran donc on
voit qu'à la fois les salariés et à la
fois les entreprises commencent à dire
ça serait bien qu'il revienne une
journée ou deux et je pense que la
solution parce qu'aujourd'hui on a que
ce soit un peu plus de 60% des
entreprises fin de tout cas des
personnes qui pourraient et travailler
qui télétravaillent je pense que la
solution c'est que tout le monde joue le
jeu et quand on aura 90 % des gens qui
vraiment télétravail
à ce moment là on pourra faire peut-être
le télétravail à 80 moins 70% et
permettre non plus sur la base du
volontariat mais à tout le monde de
revenir au moins une journée un long
temps voilà au moins une journée en
présentiel et on réglera tous les
problèmes qui sont qui sont à côté et ce
sera le mot de la fin merci beaucoup
merci à vous venez d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin merci christelle en
regardant une de la dépêche du midi
c'est guy novès à la une de la dépêche
du midi ancien manager du stade
toulousain et sélectionneur du quinze de
france qui publie une autobiographie et
donné une interview à la dépêche
à lire ce matin dans votre journal
christelle merci beaucoup en face au
club de territoire la mutuelle nationale
territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
[Musique]